if you run your services on gke or
anywhere really you need to have a way
to get some basic signals about service
health at a minimum you want to collect
the golden signals for your service
traffic is a measure of how much demand
the service is responding to usually
measured in requests or queries per
second
saturation is a measure of how much of
the available capacity the service is
using
errors or error rate should tell you the
fraction of requests you're able to
serve correctly or incorrectly
and latency is a measure of how quickly
you're able to serve your users
you can read more about golden signals
in the monitoring distributed systems
chapter of the sre book we'll link to
that below
of course you need a way to capture this
information for your services my name is
yuri i'm an sre at google cloud
and today i'm going to show you how to
instrument your python services to emit
metrics like these with open telemetry
an open source observability library
welcome back to engineering for
reliability
we'll start with walking through the
code to instrument your application then
we'll have a look at how to query and
use those metrics in cloud monitoring
our example service is written in python
using the flask framework it receives
web requests and does some processing
before responding so we'd like to track
the request rate error rate and the
distribution of the processing latency
as always we'll link to the full code
sample but here's how you can add metric
instrumentation to it
first we set up the exporter to send
metric data to the open telemetry
collector it's a dedicated component
we'll use to collect telemetry and
forward it onto cloud monitoring and
we'll cover in more detail in our next
episode
next we define the meter provider
including information about our service
we'll be able to use to query our
metrics
next we define our actual metrics we'll
use incrementing counters to track
requests and errors and a histogram to
track latency
finally we use these metrics to record
our data we increment the counters on
requested air and record latency before
returning
and now we have metrics to represent the
major signals of application health
request an error count and a latency
distribution
now that our application is instrumented
let's deploy it and have a look at the
metrics our application is written in
python and instrumented with open
telemetry
[Music]
we use this docker file to build the
container image
we use this yaml file to deploy our
image to a gke cluster
and here are the three replicas
next we create this yaml file and use it
to deploy the open telemetry collector
and here it is running in the same name
space as our application
finally we have some pods generating
traffic against our service
let's go to metrics explorer and first
look for our total request metric
we'll group it by service id
this shows the request rate by pod name
we can do the same for the failed
request metric
[Music]
we can even have cloud monitoring
calculator ratio of the two for us to
easily measure air rate for our
application
[Music]
finally let's also graph request leads
because this is a histogram metric we
can use a heat map this will
automatically calculate the average and
tail latencies for our service
[Music]
so that's how you can deploy a service
instrument or with open telemetry to gke
and view its health metrics in cloud
monitoring
thanks so much for watching today we
learned how to use open telemetry to
instrument our service to emit basic
signals of application health like
traffic and latency metrics and how to
query them in cloud monitoring i hope
this helps you to keep your applications
reliable and your users happy don't
forget to like and subscribe to never
miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
[Music]